it's great to have back on the program
today brian class who's an associate
professor of global politics at
university college london and also
author of the new book corruptable who
gets power and how it changes us brian
always great to talk to you
thanks for having me so you know when we
think about something like who obtains
power in in society we could even narrow
it down and say in kind of western
democracies in capitalist western
democracies there's a lot of different
approaches we can look at we we can look
at sort of psychological factors and
personality factors about individuals we
can talk about um you know the leg up
that the economic circumstances that one
is born into might
play as a factor uh we we can talk about
the role of media so many different
things what are some of the or maybe the
most important filters through which we
can start to think about who ends up
holding power in society
yes so i think that the most of the
debate around people in power is like a
tip of the iceberg problem where we tend
to focus almost all of our attention on
the people who are actually in power the
ones who we can see right the top of the
iceberg and the real problem i think we
have is underneath the surface which is
the people who don't seek power
and so you know you think about like a
high school basketball team you never
expect that basketball team to be a
representative sample of height in the
school right there's a certain group of
people that are going to try out for the
team the same is obviously true with
power now i've looked you know the book
draws on a wide variety of research from
evolutionary biology to neuroscience and
psychology and so on so i started to ask
people who study this is there a power
gene is there something in us that
causes us to seek power and there is a
study that shows uh a significant
correlation between a specific gene and
people who end up in power but we can't
say whether that's because they have
certain traits they're more outgoing
they're more affable whatever but we do
have some evidence that there is some
genetic basis to power attainment and
then of course you filter that through
all the stuff in society where
you know i mean it's obvious that white
men are
have an easier time getting power in
western democracies
but also that we seek certain things uh
in in our rulers and and this ranges
from everything from evolutionary
psychology where we look at you know why
is it that we turn to strong men in
times of crises
to this amazing study i found about
basically asking children to pick
someone to captain their imaginary ship
in this computer simulation and they
basically are shown two faces
and there's no other information given
they pick one of the faces to be the
captain what they don't know is that the
two faces are the winner and the
runner-up of the french parliamentary
elections
and with astonishing accuracy they tend
to pick the winner which reflects this
horrible truth that often we have such
superficial assessments when we pick
leaders so
there are dozens of reasons why this
happens but i think we have to
acknowledge the problem and the
self-selection that goes into power
before we can actually fix it with some
of these things there would be sort of a
legitimate question to ask about
uh it's sort of like a chicken egg thing
uh and i'll explain what i mean when we
think about the alleged uh corrupting
influence of power
you
it's often said that absolute power
corrupts but is there something about
corrupt people who are already corrupt
predisposed to put themselves in those
positions that kind of reverses the
causation
yeah so i'll answer with in two ways the
the first is that there's this there's
this other study that i found phenomenal
where it basically asks people to roll a
dice and it says if you roll a six you
get more money if you roll a wine you
get no money right so there's an
incentive to lie about it so they you
know there's variations of how many
people cheat in this basically but what
they found was that when they ran this
study in corrupt countries like in india
where being a civil servant is somewhere
where you can get off the books pay
what happened was the people who lied
about their dice rolls were
disproportionately likely to want to
become civil servants they did this at a
school if you do the exact same study in
somewhere like denmark it's exactly the
opposite the people who report their
stores
their scores completely honestly they're
the ones who want to go into public
service so a corrupt system draws in
corrupt people and a clean system draws
in clean people so the system really
really matters i talk about this
actually in an essay i have out in the
atlantic today with policing in the
united states so
there's this there's this phenomenon
that i think doesn't get enough
attention when we talk about body
cameras and trying to change what the
police do with police reforms
and we have to think about who the
police are and who wants to become a
police officer
so you know i looked at this ad that was
used for recruitment in doraville
georgia this this town of 10 000 people
outside of lance atlanta
and it's i mean it's a caricature right
it's literally like these guys in a tank
driving through uh in the sort of you
know the punisher logo is flashing on
screen about vigilante justice they
throw smoke grenades out that's you know
that's the image of policing
i talked to new zealand's police force
and they basically tried to counteract
this so they ran
a multi-year recruitment scheme that
used funny videos made policing look
enjoyable all about public service had
lots of women and ethnic minorities in
it and their applications shot through
the roof fernan through the roof for
non-traditional officers and their abuse
levels fell at the same time so you know
i think that there's
an acknowledgement we have to make that
the way we perceive systems of power
really really matters for who seeks it
and it's why i'm particularly worried
about what's happening in the u.s right
now with these
insane zealots threatening school board
members for you know mass mandates and
so on because they're making public
service toxic and they're going to
ensure that good decent people just
simply self-select out of systems of
power and that we're left with the
people who the insane zealots basically
agree with putting their hat in the ring
right you have that issue you also have
i mean it's not necessarily related to
what we're talking about here but i've
pointed out that those who want to hurt
uh public education funded through taxes
love the school board stuff because they
see it as hey if if these schools seem
really chaotic it might encourage
parents to say i'm pulling my kid out
i'm going to do homeschooling private
school whatever which will of course
further weaken schools and and sort of
sort of exacerbate let's go back a
little bit to the police thing because
that's interesting and you've talked
about that um
there recently two stories on policing
have sort of come together one is
what was sort of increased by the george
floyd protests and questions of police
brutality and bad apples that spawned
the
that spoil the bunch etc we also have
the anti-vaccine stuff which is leading
to it really doesn't seem like more than
one percent in the worst cases of
officers leaving you know 34 officers in
new york city out of 36 000
a few emails that came in people said
hey you know when we talk about the bad
apples that spoil the bunch on the
police brutality stuff it might be the
same people who are now leaving because
of the vaccine stuff this could be a
blessing in disguise but that's not
really a strategy for dealing with with
this issue of policing what is your
sense of you know there's the reform
movement there's the uh defund movement
there's all these different ideas and
approaches you mentioned one in in new
zealand that was a very different
approach how should we be thinking about
big picture the issue of policing in the
united states and who is doing the
policing
yeah so i mean the stuff i talked about
in new zealand is a first step which is
to say you need to make the police
appealing to normal decent people who
want to serve the public that don't have
a military background right veterans are
overrepresented in the police
dramatically in the u.s by design by the
way and that's not necessarily a problem
it's just that you know if you think
that your job is the same as when you're
patrolling fallujah when you're in
ferguson
that's going to be an issue you're going
to be more likely to be a little
trigger-happy and so on and we need a
lot more community officers that have no
background in the military and actually
don't want power so the recruitment is
part of it there's other stuff i write
about in the book that's about how you
sort of deter abuses for people once
they're in power
you know i think it is easier to recruit
good apples than it is to make bad
apples behave better but we do have bad
apples in the police so what are we
gonna do one of the keys is rotation so
there's a lot of studies that look at
how uh comfort and sort of closed
systems create abuse
so in police for example this is the
sort of blue wall of silence and the
sort of your partner will always have
your back even if you're doing something
really illegal and abusive
so the metropolitan police in london for
example did some work of rotating
partners through regularly and it had
really good results and there's also
loads of psychological research where
you have
participants play games basically in
which they can collude in order to win
money and if you work with the same
person through multiple rounds of the
game the odds that you're going to try
to give bribes to win the game go
massively through the roof compared to
if you're constantly rotating people
through because you have you know this
sort of fresh face that you don't know
is necessarily on your side and
interestingly this data shows the same
thing whether they run it in germany or
china or the u.s so you know i have at
the end of the book there's this section
on on 10 ways to fix the problem and
they're basically things that all need
to happen because there's no silver
bullet this is a massive problem but the
point that i'm trying to make here is
that we don't think about systems of
power enough this way we have to design
every single system from the police to
politics with the assumption which is
true by the way that bad people are
disproportionately likely to seek power
disproportionately likely to get it and
disproportionately likely to be able to
stay in it longer than they should and
so once you take that as the starting
point then you redesign the system and
think how can we invert that and i think
nothing has been tried i mean that
that's the thing that i find so
maddening is that all of the debates
around police
i mean there's some defund movements and
so on that have their ideas about you
know fundamentally transforming policing
but the rest of them body cameras i mean
it's a good idea but is that really
going to solve the problem there's a
thousand people who are getting killed
by cops in the united states every year
in new zealand there's about a dozen a
decade right maybe less than that so
obviously the population is different
but we have a massive massive problem on
our hands and i don't think around the
edges or forums are going to solve it
what are the different fields in which
these dynamics uh are are a problem i
mean i think police is one that gets a
lot of attention politicians and and you
know psychopathy predispositions is
sometimes talked about i think corporate
ceos is one that gets discussion we
don't hear about this dynamic among
postal workers or nurses for example so
like what what are the other fields
where these dynamics uh show up more
well it's it's it's very interesting you
ask that because there's there's two
sections in the book where i try to
bring this dynamic much closer to home
and there's one which is a really crazy
story uh about this guy named steve
rauchi who is a psychopathic custodian
in schenectady new york and in order to
raise rise to the ranks in his school
district he did some crazy stuff i mean
he started us using explosives and all
he's in jail for a very long time now um
and and that job that was just a
personality trait so that's if you have
a psychopath who's power hungry you put
them in anywhere and they're gonna try
to rise through the ranks through any
means necessary but there's actually as
you say a trait to this that is
disproportionately selecting in certain
jobs so politics is an obvious one but
also one that's really interesting is a
place where you have power for the sake
of power with no real other benefits so
i explore this with homeowners
associations there's a great uh a great
series of stories that i've i've
discovered and and characters that are
very interesting people who basically
you know it's it's like this horrible
job where you you spend your time trying
to impose fines on somebody down the
block who put their bin out you know 10
minutes too early or something on a
sunday
who's that going to appeal to when the
pay is either non-existent or terrible
well it's the person who's power hungry
and can't fulfill that in another area
of life so
those types of positions are also
magnets for power abusers which is why
you get what we call the petty tyrants
effect the person who rules over a
completely insignificant domain but is
going to abuse every possible ounce of
power that they have and i think that's
something that a lot of people
experience in their daily lives as a as
a general rule are
the approaches that are more likely or
have worked more effectively
about as you mentioned with police it's
higher good apples rather than convert
it does that apply universally
yeah you you sort of need to do all of
the above to be honest because
the problem is not just the individual
it's also the system right i mean if you
have a good person who goes into a
rotten police department they're gonna
probably behave in a rotten way and one
of the more unusual things that i did
that might be of interest to your
viewers and listeners is i took a ski
lesson with paul bremmer who ran iraq in
2003 and now he's a ski instructor in
vermont believe it or not so he's an
interesting case study because you know
a lot of people see him as the villain
and i understand completely why i mean
what he did in 2003 you know the the
record speaks for itself but what's
interesting about him is that he was
previously an ambassador to malawi and
norway and it appears that he did a very
good job i mean across most people think
that he was really effective
and sort of had lots of integrity in
that position and so on and then he goes
into iraq where everything is broken and
he's basically you know a de facto
viceroy of a dictatorship and all of a
sudden everything he has to do is these
awful decisions with morally dubious
consequences and so on and so i think
one of the things that we also have to
acknowledge it's not to absolve people
who do bad things in positions of power
it's that it's more complicated
sometimes than it initially appears and
that the system also needs our attention
because
you know i i like to think that i would
behave well no matter what but you know
you see the evidence from around the
world and you you take people and put
them in new systems and they do behave
in different ways there's a study of
bankers in italy where southern italy is
known as being more corrupt than
northern italy yes and the employees who
move between the same bank but different
branches start embezzling at higher
rates if they're in the south so you
know there's things like that where we
can see that it's both the individual
and the system that need our attention
um
i i this may seem like a sort of
divergence but but i i think it it could
be an interesting one the role of power
within uh other species within within
the animal kingdom um what do we know
that mirrors homo sapiens and what what
differences are there
yeah it's a great question it's one of
the most enjoyable parts of the research
because you know i'm a political
scientist so i don't spend a lot of time
with people who study hyenas and bees
and primates and so on but i did for the
book yeah and it was really really
fascinating primates are a great window
for us because it's
similar in terms of some of the brain
functions and some social structures
without the culture right and so
you can look at how power affects
individuals there's an amazing study i i
interviewed a professor and doctor
out in north carolina who
looks at hierarchy and drug addiction in
macaque monkeys
and one of the craziest things is that
when you basically give monkeys you put
them in groups of four they instantly
form a hierarchy from one to four
and then you offer them the choice
between cocaine where they push a button
and they get intravenous cocaine or
banana pellets they push a different
button and they get banana pellets and
what's what's amazing about this is that
every time you run this study the top
two monkeys the ones that are on the top
of the hierarchy don't take the cocaine
they take the banana pellets the ones
who are on the bottom
basically self-medicate
and this happens even if the alpha male
in this group gets reassigned to another
group of four and then ends up on the
bottom all of a sudden the exact same
thing happens so it doesn't matter about
the individual i also looked at
corruption in believe it or not bees and
wasps and it's an amazing story about
systems and individual behavior i won't
go into the whole story but basically
the the gist of it is the way the hive
is set up between different kinds of
species of wasps whether it's
transparent or not whether it's easy to
detect wrongdoing or not by what are
actually called police wasps or police
bees
that has a massive massive effect on how
selfish the behavior of the individual
wasp or b is
and i think these lessons that we have
from the animal kingdom are actually
quite instructive because
most of the time when we talk about
these problems we're talking about them
within the silos of democrats and
republicans yeah and sometimes it's
worth stripping that away and saying
okay there's some universal lessons that
we can learn and we might as well draw
them from wherever we can even if it's
from an unexpected place that's super
interesting yeah and and uh not that
long ago i read jared diamond's book the
third chimpanzee which also talks a lot
about um sort of the parts that are
analogous and parts that are not between
humans and and chimpanzees and there's
uh there's a lot of different layers to
that that you don't really see if the
focus is like american partisan politics
i guess is the point that you're making
yeah i mean i i think that there's some
some problems in society that actually
can be solved right i mean i think we
focus on so much stuff that is the
partisan battle of the day which makes
complete sense yeah but we can actually
make systems of power behave better for
all of us and that requires some
outside-the-box thinking that might have
reference points that aren't our typical
culture wars right you know it's hard to
get worked up about uh you know somebody
making a point about
wasp corruption for example it's not
exactly gonna rile you up in the same
way
and so on so i i think we can draw these
lessons the other point that i make by
the way is i as part of the research
this book i interviewed i met with lots
of really awful people i i met with lots
of former despots war criminals all
sorts
around the world and one of the points
that i often make is you would find it
super weird if somebody who was an
expert on hyenas
never
encountered a hyena never studied one
never went up to one and observed it and
yet there's a lot of stuff in politics
where these monsters among us still are
living breathing and willing to talk to
people so
i went to study them to figure out what
makes them tick and what power does to
them and i think we need to do more of
that because these problems are
preventable but we have to sort of strip
away some of the the the sort of
preconceptions or
uh revulsion that we have and start to
think okay we're stuck with some of
these people how can we make them behave
better how can we replace them how can
we make sure that better people follow
them and that requires
some sort of outside the partisan frame
thinking i think
the book is corruptable who gets power
and how it changes us we've been
speaking with the book's author brian
class brian so great uh talking about
this and always really appreciate your
time
thanks david thanks for having me